so in the media recently in particular
on the bbc website there was a lot of um
interest a lot of information about a
wonderful new type of touchpad
technology that is going to be
introduced into phones
and touchscreens and various other types
of household products very soon and this
is something called quantum tunneling or
based around a material called a quantum
tunneling composite
to explain it we obviously have to get
back into the wacky world of quantum
mechanics and try and understand what
the hell quantum tunneling is
what actually is quantum tunneling it's
another one of these bizarre quantum
mechanical effects that arise because
although we've got this picture in our
heads of small particles electrons
protons even atoms
being like this being like little
footballs in fact they're not they have
a wave like characteristic as well and
instead of being found definitively in
this position
the the the
particle can be found here here here
here here here right across a region of
space it's not it doesn't have a fixed
location in space if we've got a
football if we're going in classical
world and it's coming along and it comes
across to a barrier it bounces off that
barrier
unless it's got an incredible amount of
energy that it actually passes straight
through that you know bulldozes through
the door remarkably with quantum
mechanics because you've got the
probability of finding the the particle
here here here here here
and importantly the other side of this
door
does uh
because you've got a probability of
finding the other side of the door it
means that the particle can actually go
right through the door
even more bizarrely there's a
probability that the particle would be
inside the door inside the barrier if
you and i were playing hide and seek yep
there would be a probability that you
were hiding in this room and there would
be a probability that you were hiding
out there in the corridor yes but to get
to the corridor you would have had to
get through the door yes yeah did the
particle no the quantum mechanically the
particle can literally pass through the
door it doesn't have to open the door it
can get through
this barrier this appears mad this idea
of particles actually passing through
solid objects and it seems like quite an
esoteric weird phenomenon turns out that
quantum tunneling pops up absolutely
everywhere the reason the sun shines the
fundamental reason the sun shines is
because ultimately particles
protons tunnels through a barrier in
this case it's it's a it's an energy
barrier so what you have are two um
particles two positively charged clumps
that come together now that we know that
like charges repel that repulsion for
those protons is very very large but
because they're not really little balls
because they have a wave like character
and because you can the probability of
finding them at different positions
varies there is actually a probability
that they're found close enough together
to trigger that fusion reaction my
computer the hard disk in my computer
that's in since about 2005 there's been
the development of what are called
tunneling magneto resistance
hard disks and these are based
fundamentally on the tunneling of
electrons through a barrier another
example is a flash memory in fact the
way these work um this random access
memory devices is that you store charge
um store electronic charge um via on a
computer chip of course and the way you
actually clear that is that the
electrons tunnel through a barrier so
coming back to this technology this
wonderful new touch phone new touch pad
touch screen technology how does it work
well what we have are nano particles
small chunks of matter which are range
between two up to 50 nanometers so those
size limits aren't particularly well
defined and the key thing that's
happening here is that you're taking
those nanoparticles you're moving them
together or moving them apart and you're
changing the rate of tunneling between
those those two nanoparticles so let's
start off so that the nanoparticles in
the film look like this they're
separated by quite a large distance
there's very little probability if any
for an electron to actually
move from particle to particle to
particle so i come in with my thumb
imagine on this scale a very massive
thumb comes in squeezes the polymer and
what happens is that you actually move
those particles together and you're
changing the rate of tunneling between
those those two nanoparticles so you're
changing what i mean by you're changing
the rate at which electrons can can move
across this gap between the particles
now this might seem a little strange
because when you look at that first of
all it seems that well there's no
barrier there there's just vacuum in
fact for the electrons there is a
barrier there's a very strong barrier
because you've got a gap you have got
vacuum it's just like if you took
a circuit with a battery and a bulb you
cut that the wire in that circuit and
you're left with a gap electrons won't
flow classically electrons don't flow
across the gap but if you make that gap
really really really really small down
to the nanometer level
then you will actually see electrons
flow when you change the gap between
these particles a little bit it's not
like you get a small change in in the
tunneling probability you get a huge
change in the ability it turns out that
for every angstrom for every tenth of a
nanometer in many cases you will get a
change in the probability of an order of
magnitude of a factor of ten so for
every tenth of a nanometer you move
these with these particles apart you're
typically talking about a factor of ten
changing the current between particles
so what we have here is when we bring
them together we see this rapid rise in
the in the tunneling probability we see
this rapid rise in the ability of this
film to um pass an electric current and
so simply by applying pressure
to one of these polymer films these
polymer nanoparticle hybrids you can
change it from an insulator to a metal
and in fact you can go from a resistance
of 10 to the 12
a million million ohms to one ohm by
applying pressure and so of course
that's very easy for an electronic
device to pick up that change in
resistance and from that the key thing
is that they are arguing and quite
correctly arguing that they've moved
from a two-dimensional touchscreen to a
three-dimensional touchscreen because
you've now got sensitivity to force in
that direction i guess what really
fascinates me and you know there are
other videos as part of 60 symbols where
i have waffled on about this at length
but really fascinates me we've got this
incredibly
esoteric and incredibly difficult to
grasp
concept um
or concepts related to quantum mechanics
and yet time and time again despite the
fact that there are huge philosophical
gaps in our understanding we still can
apply it and the quantum theory time and
time again when you apply to the real
world does a remarkably good job of
explaining how nature works
you